[Musique]
à la marathon bonjour bonjour merci
d'être venu sur le plateau de tv fil
pour ce vip qui vous est entièrement
consacré merci de m'avoir invité
c'est un grand plaisir ben on a la
chance de vous avoir ici parce que vous
êtes yvelines au vous travaillez tout
simplement à versailles et vous habitez
tout simplement à versailles alors voilà
un vrai dur passionnés de versailles tu
attends miyazato pour sa ville et j'aime
aussi le département des yvelines vous
voyez vous en général oui oui parce que
je trouve que c'est un département qui
est fort bien situé et où il fait bon
vivre à centrale et dites-moi a pas aimé
versailles et les yeux viennent vous
avez un travail je crois oui oui alors
que faites vous dans la vie je suis donc
jardinier à versailles je collabore à la
conservation de ce lieu hors du commun
j'orchestre le travaux les travaux des
équipes qui tous les jours et bien
oeuvre sur ce parc historique
et puis j'ai également la chance d'être
à la radio à la télévision et parfois
même d'écrire quelques ouvrages voilà
comme cette manière alors je rectifie
juste donc vous êtes chef jardinier sur
le domaine de versailles et de trianon
oui depuis 35 ans m'a-t-on dit 40 ans je
suis un à versailles c'est terrible en
1976 j'ai occupé quelques
responsabilités comme on dit aujourd'hui
depuis 1982 pour être exact accord mais
tout est parfait le grand air et bien je
travaillais dehors non oui mes
grands-pères peut-être mais la terre est
basse et vie constate que je n'ai soucis
de dos tout comme ceux qui exercent mon
métier
le mal du dos est vraiment le mal du
jardinet par définition et c'est un peu
dommage
bombay prix tirant réfléchira sur ce
problème après on va trouver une
solution
donc vous êtes chroniqueur sur france
inter le samedi matin à l'aube un petit
peu halloween pas vraiment à l'eau parce
que cette heure quarante huit heures le
samedi et le dimanche c'est peut-être
tôt mais c'est leur généralement où les
gens se réveillent prennent leur douche
leur petit déjeuner ou sont dans la
voiture pour emmener les enfants à
l'école
donc c'est un moment très écoutée et
c'est un vrai plaisir que de pouvoir
parler à des milliers des centaines de
milliers d'auditeurs millions qui écoute
des milieux
il ya l on y arrivera peut-être
et c'est vrai que c'est une de joie pour
moi que de m'exprimer rasé et puis de
rencontrer les grands noms de la radio
non pas que jamais comme toi ça va quand
on parle de ceux qui tiennent un micro
oui les grandes radios on pense toujours
au plaisir qu'ils ont de s'adresser à
des anonymes mais on a également la
chance de rencontrer des gens absolument
incroyable je me rappelle des
conversations avec par monsieur claude
villers ce qui était quand même un grand
nom de la radio j'ai beaucoup aimé josé
artur j'ai fréquenté jacques paul
stephan poli avec qui j'ai collaboré
pendant trois ans sur france inter ivan
levaï noëlle bréham fait partie de
celles également elle qui m'a donné
envie de faire de la radio
c'est quand on les écoute c'est toute
une poésie qui rentre dans votre post ce
sont des gens qui donnent du bonheur
d'accord mépris que vous en faites
partie maintenant depuis un certain
temps donc comme on le disait et vous
n'avez pas que c'est donc vous êtes
chroniqueurs vous avez aussi donc vous
donner des conseils aux audits à y
croire assuré du mieux que je le sais
pas qui c'est mais des questions voilà
parce qu'il est toujours très difficile
d'expliquer par la voix ce que vit une
plante que si vous voyez pas le
l'officier et puis il faut être positif
également les gens qui vous écoute vous
écoute pour passer un moment agréable
je ne peux pas être trop parfois
j'allais dire pessimiste parce que
malheureusement on confond trop jardiner
et sorciers je n'ai pas le pouvoir
malheureusement de sauver de la mort les
armes ou les arbustes condamné donc
j'essaie de tout autour de positiver de
mettre une petite touche d'humour parce
que je crois qu'il faut donner le
sourire rouge à ceux qui m'écoutent et
puis également de la coquinerie parce
que le jardin c'est la vie d'accord avec
tout ce qu'elle comporte
ben oui bien simple aucun ou pas
celui-là n'est pas très coquin du tout a
dit une éternité pour mais il est en
même temps très très ravissante c'est
pas le mot gracieux c'est pas le mot
mais vraiment je ne trouve pas bon mais
très agréable très très intime
ben je trouve moi j'ai découvert un
petit garçon à la baratte ont de 15 ans
qui n'est pas présent dans tous les cas
ce qu'on fait dans ce lieu qui s'appelle
le camille el ma mère il faut quand même
le nommer vous partez d'une plante que
votre maman affectionnait tout
particulièrement à savoir un camélia
tout planté à arès sur le bassin
d'arcachon voilà auparavant planter chez
votre grand père un homme délicieux qui
m'a donné envie d'être jardiner et c'est
cette histoire j'ai eu envie de raconter
l'histoire de ce camélia qui a voyagé
qui a résisté à la tempête qui a résisté
surtout à sept enfants tous plus
terribles les uns que les autres
je suis à fond et nous sommes toujours
des sept enfants imaginer les ballons
qu'il a dû recevoir l'absence d'arrosage
que nous étions supposés nous en occuper
donc ce qu'amélie est un miraculé
mais surtout surtout j'ai appris avec
les années
certaines choses sur camélia que je
n'aurais complètement saviez vous par
exemple 0 n'est que quand vous buvez du
thé sont des feuilles de camélia que
vous consommez ça serait bien sûr que
c'est vrai c'est le camélia de chine et
je suis comme une histoire
extraordinaire a raconté celle de chine
le camélia du japon celui qui fleurit
merveilleusement qui va inspirer dumas
qui va inspirer vernis qui inspire et
les grands auteurs et puis et 8 le
camélia de ma mère je suis dit tiens je
racontais l'histoire du camellia le vrai
le en général dans les revues par les
yeux de madame
d'accord et alors justement quand vous
dites le cas mais là de ma mère votre
maman c'était complètement approprié cet
arbuste vous dit même que quand elle
s'en approchait quand il était en forme
resplendissante fleury elle-même
paraissait plus belles rajeuni plus
heureuse et ait cette fonction qu'elle
arbustes sur votre maman de josé maya
liste de liens très forts au niveau de
l'affectivité c'est souvent ça existe ça
finalement des gens qui s'approprie une
fleur moi j'ai ma grand-mère qui déballe
son numéro c'est rosa elle m'aimait bien
sûr je travaille à verser vous le disiez
lien entre je vois des gens qui viennent
parler aux arbres qui viennent caresser
leur écorce et qui ont besoin du contact
avec les jets d'eau pour nour pour ma
maman sont camélias c'est tout
simplement déjà le fait de retrouver en
juillet août c'était l'époque des
vacances elle ne le voyais mal
heureusement que quand un client en
fleurs mais mais se réconforter à à
compter les boutons sécher lorsqu'elle
arrive est malheureusement trop tard
elle a eu ensuite la chance de le
découvrir en pleine floraison mais ce
camélias c'est le souvenir de son père
ce le souvenir des jours heureux quand
les enfants ne donne pas encore de
soucis
c'est également le souvenir c'est le
passé c'est le futur c'est la promesse
de lendemains qui chantent
une plante s'est pas seulement donc à
végétal qui les pousse avec un peu d'eau
et du sol et non ce sont des émotions ce
sont des des souvenirs c'est une âme
et puis espoir c'est quand tu étais
d'espoir quand vous avez un végétal
quand vous plantez un camélia le sol la
seule chose que vous attendez de lui
c'est que vous offrent des fleurs
n'était ce pas le plus beau des cadeaux
monsieur lorsqu'un média est une plante
qui a symbolisé longtemps la halle à la
baule à l'élégance la beauté la saison
il était blanc sont camélia parce
qu'elle s'inscrivait dans la grande dans
la grande lignée de l'aristocratie
lequel mme éliette une fleur qui n'est
pas vulgaire
quand vous portez à camélia la
boutonnière vous êtes élégant vous êtes
chic on n'a pas voulu pour des raisons
de superstition armor et annonay et
c'est dommage car le
du fort hills est très bon et c'est une
très belle coupe de seconde par dans sa
très mal élevé mais quelle est la fleur
vulgaire selon vous vous dites que
camille avait pas vulgaire 10 des fleurs
vulgaire non il existe existe peut-être
des fleurs un peu exubérante moins chic
où je n'aime finir ma chique
voilà j'aime moyennement toutes ces
plantes originaires par exemple des
antilles et qui cliquent lyon des tirs
très vives
quelles sont elles sont très belles dans
leur milieu d'origine
mais dans un vase n'empêche elle son
voile à la place elles sont trouvés
luberon je comprends et vous alors votre
maman avait son camélia ma grand-mère
avait ses roses et vous est-ce que vous
avez une fleur particulière un arbuste
particulier dans votre jardin de
versailles qui est à vous qui est votre
prolongement alors déjà quantité de 2,2
gens que j'aime beaucoup sur venet à
versailles et planter des apps
moi même je vais planter un arbre c'est
un être pur plus les magnifiques
non c'était pas le mien c'était pas le
lien c'est celui de mon épouse
parce que je n'ai pas voulu planter
d'arbres pour moi j'aurai le sentiment
de voler une parcelle du domaine de
versailles qui comprend mon rôle est de
veiller oui d'accord je comprends à la
santé des arbres des autres est ce que
vous voulez venir dans mon jardin planté
votre arbre là pourquoi pas un combat
mais tout de même c'est que mon arbre
risque de vous décevoir qu'invente j'ai
un arbre préféré j'ai un arbre fétiche
c'est quoi un chêne est ce que c'est oui
par exemple mais ses fins ce sont des
arbres qu'ils sont beaux qu'ils sont
nobles qui peuvent vivre des centaines
d'années qui ne demandent pas de soins
pour être magnifique et surtout qu'ils
n'ont pas besoin de l'homme pour vivre
pleinement
donc j'aime bien les couples elle
continue willy basque oui parce que je
ne dépends ce sont des arbres que l'on
ne t'avait pas beaucoup non plus oui
j'ai testé conseil les arbres au bout
d'un moment je me demandais que c'est
vraiment c'est notre rôle que de
contraindre la nature m'a écoutée sur
ces belles paroles
nous allons nous quitter oui et donc moi
je recommande la lecture de ce petit
livre absolument charmant je trouve
qu'il ya parfois un peu de marcel pagnol
dans ce livre franchement j'aimerais que
vous nous racontiez un peu plus votre
enfance un peu plus en détails parce que
la tribu tiquement on vous découvre un
petit peu mais s'il vous plaît on envoie
ans d'autres enfants sont votre jeunesse
si la prochaine fois
raconte pas que des fleurs et des arbres
avec plaisir à merci au revoir alors
voir merci d'être venus
[Musique]